[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage et d'expertise sur public
c'est la 90 minutes pour donner du sens
à l'actualité et justement c'est une
étape majeure de la réforme des
retraites qui va s'ouvrir demain au
Sénat 15 jours pour examiner le fond
d'un texte et fleurer dans le chaos à
l'Assemblée et la gauche sénatoriale qui
reproche au gouvernement d'avoir
raccourci la durée des débats avec
l'article 47.1 de la Constitution
le recours donc à cet article
Savary ce sera dans 45 minutes mais
d'abord on détaille les stratégies
politiques attendues au Sénat et les
modifications de la loi acceptables par
le gouvernement avec qui en effet les
se démarquer du tumulte de l'Assemblée
les sénateurs en font leur priorité la
chambre haute se donne 11 jours
d'examens en séance contre neuf au
Palais Bourbon un climat plus apaisé et
davantage de temps pour discuter dans
ces conditions la majorité sénatoriale
entend examiner l'ensemble du texte et
nous nous avons une responsabilité parce
que c'est notre mission
parlementaire que d'aller jusqu'au bout
et de sortir si je puis dire par un vote
la majorité de droite et du centre
compte bien amender le texte du
Gouvernement le président de la
République puis la première ministre ont
tout de afficher leur ouverture moi j'ai
noté une volonté du Sénat de voter cette
réforme des retraites il y a des
demandes d'amélioration on va évidemment
les examiner les républicains ont fixé
un certain nombre d'impératif sur
l'équilibre financier ou une surcote
pour les maires de familles notamment la
droite se sit en position de force pour
reprendre la main sur les propositions
j'ai bien senti que le gouvernement
centraux ouvert de toute façon il y a
pas le choix
sans cette ligne là qui est une ligne
rouge pour nous sans ce point là jamais
nous ne voterons une réforme ni
maintenant ni en CMP ni après en
l'absence de la France insoumise au
Sénat la gauche fait savoir qu'elle ne
compte pas jouer l'obstruction à la
manière des députés nous voulons un
débat de fond sur l'article 7 et nous
voulons un vote sur l'article 7
globalement nous voulons que les 20
articles soient abordés où vont
travailler au fond nous allons
travailler avec le temps nécessaire et
si le gong tombe et bien ce sera de la
propre responsabilité du gouvernement la
gauche veut donc avancer sur le texte et
ainsi marquer son opposition mais le
groupe n'exclut pas de ralentir les
débats en fin de discussion pour
s'opposer au vote finale de la réforme
[Musique]
voilà on entre dans le cœur de l'examen
de cette réforme des retraites ici au
Sénat évidemment l'antenne sera
mobilisée presque 24 heures sur 24 pour
vous faire vivre les débats en direct et
puissance publique évidemment sera là
aussi pour analyser le plus près
possible des thématiques ce qui se
jouera au Sénat tout près d'ici je vous
présente les invités de ce débat ce soir
Erwan l'ESTRO en bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes directeur conseil à odoxa Claire
Chartier bonsoir bienvenue claire et
d'actrice en chef au pèlerin magazine
anne-charles bézina bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes constitutionnaliste et Mathieu
croissanto éditorialiste politique
bonsoir Mathieu bonsoir heureux de vous
retrouver on va s’appuyer évidemment
Erwan sur les résultats de du baromètre
au doxam mascara pour publique Sénat et
les quotidiens de la presse que tiennent
régionale pendant tout ce débats alors
on va on va picorer dedans au fur et à
mesure et je prends une première
question qui concerne les attentes des
Français concernant les sénateurs cette
idée de pas apaiser au plus digne
attendez-vous que les sénateurs mènent
des débats plus dignes apaisés que les
députés 87% de oui comment vous analysez
cette moi je dis et cet agacement en
forme de raz-de-marée parce que je le
lis évidemment en creux de ce qui s'est
passé à l'Assemblée tout à fait c'est 9
Français sur 10 qui souhaitent que les
débats soient plus apaisés c'est
beaucoup c'est profondément
réconciliateur dans la période actuelle
où on voit des opinions très fracturées
ce qu'on a vu au moment du tumulte à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est que les
Français étaient très horsés par le
raccourcissement des débats par le
gouvernement avec l'article 47-1 vous en
parliez mais aussi par l'obstruction
parlementaire des oppositions qui
avaient introduit plus de 20000
amendements ils ont eu l'impression les
Français finalement d'être privés de
débats sur le fond de la réforme des
retraites et c'est ce qui s'attendent
pour le Sénat et c'est aussi un peu tout
l'enjeu stratégique du Sénat qui va être
de réindiquer l'intérêt du débat
parlementaire la pertinence de débattre
du fond des réformes de faire échanger
les oppositions c'est un moment
parlementaire qui n'a pas eu lieu à
l'assemblée qui est attendu par les
Français j'ai tout l'enjeu pour les
sénateurs dans les prochains jours
claire Chartier est-ce que ces chiffres
ça démontre pour vous une forme d'erreur
stratégique de la part de LFI oui il me
semble pour pour ajouter à ce qui vient
d'être dit et il me semble que elle est
fille spécifiquement puisque on lui
s'est porté la responsabilité en grande
partie du tumulte du vacarme de ces
débats n'a pas saisi véritablement la
tonalité du pays je pense que ils n'ont
pas compris ils ont voulu nous jouer la
fanfare parlementaire du siècle dernier
la troisième 4e 5e République ou
s'attirait un petit peu dans tous les
sens avec des cris dans frais permanents
mais le pays a changé parce que nos
sociétés aujourd'hui elles sont
extrêmement
sensibles parce que submergé par une
violence verbale qui semble très
difficile à maîtriser qui vous tombe
dessus comme ça au travers des réseaux
sociaux par ces algorithmes en plus qui
incitent à la colère aux passions et
donc ça devient
à tous les âges on a affaire sur le
harcèlement à l'École etc enfin bon ça
peut toucher tout le monde ça tout le
monde et il me semble que de ce fait là
cette violence dont on a eu un spectacle
affligent apparu d'autant plus
déplorable et j'ajouterai qu'en plus
nous sommes dans une époque où la classe
politique est encore plus discréditée
qu'aussi que le dernier donc les deux
cumulés a rendu véritablement l'épisode
insupportable je suis d'accord avec vous
sur le l'opinion publique peut-être en
général mais la base de la France
insoumise peut-être que ça lui a plu à
moins non non pas du tout on a plus de
80% des Français quel que soit leur
tendance politique qui souhaitent des
débats plus apaisés que ça n'a été le
cas à l'Assemblée à l'Assemblée
nationale et c'est très majoritaire
également chez les sympathisants LFI
c'est ce que ce que disait claire
Chartier c'est que il y a vraiment un
rejet de la violence verbale qui plus
est dans l'institution parlementaire qui
c'est sa touche le fonctionnement de nos
institutions aussi et ça a été rejeté
massivement par les Français après il y
a quand même un poids à prendre en
compte aussi c'est que ce qui est heurté
les Français c'est aussi le
raccourcissement du débat parlementaire
par le gouvernement donc les Français
renvoient quasi dos à dos le
gouvernement et l'obstruction
parlementaire des position en tout cas
la séquence Assemblée nationale n'a pas
séduit les Français d'où les fortes
attentes au-delà même de la réforme mais
sur la méthode à l'égard du traitement
au Sénat je rappelle 50 jours au total
pour examiner le texte et ça et ça
ordonne là à partir de demain 15 au
Sénat
il faut expliquer les débats qui vont
commencer demain au Sénat ils seront
forcément différents pour des raisons
historiques pour des raisons de
d'organisation presque alors il y a
plusieurs choses il y a d'abord une
question de structure au sein du Sénat
qui fait que de toute façon on n'a pas
la même composition le Sénat est déjà de
toute façon beaucoup moins sensible aux
variations politiques puisque c'est une
assemblée élue d'élus même donc il y a
toujours une vague politique qui frappe
un petit peu moins fort le Sénat et puis
on le qualifie souvent de son a
conservateur c'était comme ça qu'on
appelait pendant les les les airs
napoléoniennes et ça a toujours été un
petit peu vrai puisque encore maintenant
on voit bien que le conservatisme enfin
en tout cas l'idée d'avoir une branche
LR très forte continue à à être affichée
au Sénat donc il y a ces raisons
structurelles voilà on n'a pas les mêmes
groupes aussi il y a pas des filles il y
a pas des reines donc déjà ça va quand
même arranger les choses et puis il y a
une culture qui c'est vrai et très
différente de faire la loi à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat mais eugar aussi à
cela c'est-à-dire que l'Assemblée
nationale est encore dans le feu elle a
aussi une représentation directe des des
élus qui en plus en ce moment avec les
réseaux sociaux aiment beaucoup
communiquer directement en
circonscription c'est moins vrai pour le
Sénat qui a le temps de travailler qui
prend souvent beaucoup de fond sur les
dossiers des analyses avaient été faite
sur la jurisprudence constitutionnelle
qui était vraiment très régulièrement
mobilisée au Sénat l'inverse des députés
donc pas la même structure et pas la
même méthode de travail ça de toute
façon c'est historique s'est avéré c'est
vrai pour le Sénat et ça le sera
forcément sur cette réforme également
claire Chartier à l'Assemblée il y a eu
aussi du travail il y a certains députés
qui ont fait le job mais on les a enfin
ils sont un peu passés sous les radars
médiatiques quoi exactement c'est ça un
petit peu vert et c'est ça l'effet l'un
des effets malheureux de ce qu'on
évoquait à l'instant c'est que il y a
quand même des signaux faibles d'une
nouvelle vitalité du Parlement qui sont
apparues même si donc les occasions
étaient manquées parce que ce qui
s'exprime les Français c'est aussi ça
c'est une occasion manquée en fait de de
d'un retour d'un vrai parlementarisme et
j'en veux pour preuve Jérôme Guedj qui a
quand même c'est grâce à lui en fait
qu'on a levé le lièvre de cette fameuse
retraite à 1200 euros parce que
finalement bien peu de français parce
que fort de ses qualités de coprésident
de la mission d'évaluation des lois de
programmation de la sécurité sociale et
bien il est allé demander à la sécurité
sociale des documents il a regardé
dedans et il s'est aperçu
qu'effectivement le discours du
gouvernement ne tenait pas et donc à
placer le gouvernement face à ces
contradictions donc ça c'est vraiment un
boulot de députés tel qu'on l'entend et
et effectivement on ne dans ce brouhaha
on n'a pas forcément tout à fait compris
l'importance que ça revêtait aujourd'hui
dans dans cette époque de revitalisation
parlementaire Mathieu pour vous cette
examen de la réforme des retraites c'est
l'occasion d'une triple revanche du
Sénat oui alors la première revanche
évidemment une revanche sur l'exécutif
depuis quelques semaines et même de
quelques mois c'est simple tout le monde
ne joue plus que par le Sénat au sommet
de l'État c'est un concert de louange on
loue il faut les entendre les ministres
louer l'ambiance apaisée qui règne au
Palais du Luxembourg l'esprit de sérieux
et de responsabilité le travail sur le
fond alors personne n'est dupe de ces
soudaines déclarations d'amour le Sénat
avec sa stabilité sa majorité claire sa
tradition et puis surtout on en parlait
son absence de représentants LFI et RN
c'est quand même devenu un terrain de
jeu beaucoup plus engageant et beaucoup
plus fréquentable pour le gouvernement
que le champ de mine qui est devenu le
Palais Bourbon mais tout de même quand
même quel sacrée revanche pour la route
assemblée dans les relations avec
Emmanuel Macron avait été jusque-là
teintée de méfiance réciproque quand ce
n'était pas carrément d'affrontement
plus ou moins feutrés souvenez-vous hein
la réforme constitutionnelle torpillée
par les sénateurs souvenez vous la
commission d'enquête Benalla
souvenez-vous les déclarations
d'Emmanuel Macron pour transformer
c'était son mot la haute assemblé bref
autant de griefs qui ont été aujourd'hui
oubliés alors la vérité c'est que
l'absence de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale a rebattu les cartes et du
coup redonne au Sénat un rôle de pivot
voire de points d'appui pour le
gouvernement pour faire passer ses lois
et on l'a vu sur d'autres textes et on
le voit aujourd'hui sur les retraites
donc en revanche sur l'exécutif la
deuxième c'est une revanche sur
l'assemblée avec l'examen du projet de
loi sur la réforme des retraites les
sénateurs vont pouvoir jouer sur du
velours aussi épais que leur moquette
parce que faut dire que leurs collègues
députés leur ont facilité la tâche le
spectacle lamentable d'évitement et
d'obstructions d'invectives et de
digression offert par l'Assemblée en
première lecture aboutit au pire
puisqu'on a eu un texte mal débattu un
examen inachevé et au final un projet de
loi qui a pas été voté c'est donc une
tactique bien différente que ça prête à
adopter les sénateurs on l'a vu hier en
commission avec un projet de loi amendé
améliorer là aussi un vrai boulot de
parlementaire pour rebondir sur ce que
disait clair sur sur l'assemblée et puis
les débats même s'ils vont être
vigoureux en séance publique ils seront
pas inutilement virulents l'opposition
de gauche à la déposer 10 fois moins
d'amendement que que nous l'avez fait
les députés elle entend bien faire
valoir ses arguments mais en jouant son
rôle c'est à dire en examinant le texte
on a entendu tout à l'heure dans la dans
la bouche de Patrick kaner et puis la
droite plus cohérente au Sénat qu'à
l'Assemblée s'apprête à voter la réforme
qui ressemble il faut quand même le dire
comme deux gouttes d'eau à celle qu'elle
vote pour le symbole chaque année depuis
4 ans donc on a deux revanche c'est quoi
la troisième mais sur l'opinion Hardy un
volet des années que le Sénat n'a pas
bonne presse quand même faut le dire
qu'on se moque plus ou moins gentiment
plutôt moins que plus des sénateurs
qu'on qualifie le Sénat d'anomalies dans
parmi les démocraties ça c'était Lionel
Jospin en 98 ou qu'on propose carrément
de le supprimer comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon
dans ses programmes présidentiels ou
comme les gilets jaunes dans leur
manifestation en fait l'institution
sénatoriale elle est méconnue du grand
public et elle tient la l'occasion de
faire la démonstration de son utilité en
jouant son rôle de contrepoids et
d'équilibre que lui confère notre vie
politique sous l'oeil de toutes les
caméras de France s'il vous plaît donc
ça c'est l'enjeu en arrière de la
réforme des retraites qui mieux pour le
coup tout le monde d'accord toute
sensibilité confondues au Palais du
Luxembourg effectivement
claire Chartier le il est long moi je
retiens ce que vous dites sur le le
début du premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron l'affaire Benalla enfin faut se
souvenir de l'état de tension qui peut y
avoir entre l'exécutif et le Sénat à ce
moment-là quoi
je veux dire vraiment là et d'ailleurs
Emmanuel Macron l'a montré là le le la
danse du ventre on peut même dire
véritablement c'est de cet ordre là à
destination à la fois de LR et
effectivement de ces sénateurs qui
paraissent beaucoup plus sage que le
reste est que même que leur Corée
légionnaire du Parlement cela dit c'est
pas quand même très facile quand même
pour cette droite parce que malgré tout
dans l'opinion publique on a bien
compris qu'il y avait divergences quand
même entre les députés et entre les
sénateurs
c'est pour ça que je t'enverrai un peu
je me dirais un peu parce que ça ça
colore un petit peu le les choses et on
n'est pas certain que ça se passe
comment dire que ça soit aussi simple
alors sur cette
différence de de ton de travail de fond
attendus au Sénat écoutez ce qu'on dit
le centriste Hervé Marseille c'était sur
notre antenne
montrer la différence avec l'Assemblée
nationale c'est assez paradoxal qu'une
assemblée parlementaire s'organise
j'allais dire presque scientifiquement
pour s'effacer je veux dire pas tous les
députés vous avez remarqué vous voyez à
peu près à qui je suis allusion bon un
spectacle affligent mais surtout
institutionnellement cette assemblée qui
dans la Constitution à la prééminence
puisqu'elle a le dernier mot c'est
organisé pour s'effacer et pour ne pas
débattre pour ne pas travailler pour ne
pas voter j'aimerais bien vous entendre
là dessus Anne bézina l'assemblée qui
s'organise pour s'effacer effectivement
c'est c'est pas dans la tradition dans
la tradition républicaine française
alors c'est pas la première fois que le
Sénat aura l'occasion de démontrer qu'il
travaille plus au fond que l'Assemblée
nationale et qu'il arrive parfois à
demander dans un sens substantiel les
lois ça faut le redire on a beaucoup de
grief contre le Sénat mais le Sénat
enrichit les lois et ça c'est une
réalité statistique néanmoins l'idée
d'une assemblée qui s'efface c'est vrai
que c'est complètement ce qui s'est
passé étant donné que l'Assemblée
nationale c'est le deal de l'article 47
1 qu'on en pense qu'on en pense de toute
façon savait qu'elle avait 20 jours
initialement et l'idée de jouer la
montre c'est soit de se dire de toute
façon j'utilise ces 20 jours pour
bloquer soit je utilise pour aller le
plus vite possible pour voter et c'est
vrai qu'on avait du mal au départ à se
dire que l'Assemblée nationale se
priverait complètement d'un vote parce
que le vote c'est quoi le vote c'est
quand même l'idée d'avoir au moins
offert à la population l'idée d'un débat
sur le fond et puis en plus d'avoir
offert aussi aux circonscriptions
l'occasion de montrer qu'elles ont été
entendues on a beaucoup dit que les
députés étaient sous pression de la rue
et c'est sûrement vrai puisque c'est
vrai que les députés en circonscription
en entendait des vertes et des pas mûres
et donc ont eu le sentiment qui ne
pouvait pas soutenir la réforme autant
qu'il l'aurait cru mais dans tous les
cas le vote c'était vraiment le moment
sacré pour lequel on s'attendait
évidemment pas à ce que l'Assemblée
nationale fasse tout pour essayer
d'éviter alors est-ce qu'après c'est un
jeu volontaire est-ce que l'Assemblée
nationale a vraiment voulu ne pas en
arriver au vote c'est pas sûr c'est
juste que la stratégie d'opposition a
vraiment été tellement mal pensée
il a conduit à une perte de temps tout
est stratégie
Erwan tout à l'heure le choix du
gouvernement de cette procédure oui
articulaire et qu'il faut quand même
souligner parce que c'est d'autant plus
dommage que ce projet de loi il est mal
fiché il est malfagoté on a l'impression
qu'il a été écrit sur un coin de table
on découvre au fur et à mesure des
débats qu'il y a plein de trous dans la
raquette on l'a vu sur la question des
femmes on l'a vu sur la pénibilité on
l'a vu sur la question des carrières qui
notamment pour ceux qui commençaient
entre 20 et 21 ans pour lequel rien
n'avait été prévu on le voit pour cette
retraite cette pension minimale à 1200
euros qui s'avère en fait bien plus
réduite en termes de nombre de
bénéficiaires que ce que stimait le le
place pour un vrai travail parlementaire
d'autant que la retraite c'est quand
même un enjeu essentiel qui nous touche
tous et donc qui aurait mérité argument
contre argument amendement contrairement
qu'on puisse débattre au fond pas
seulement du report de Las Vegas 64 ans
mais aussi de tout le tricot qui est
autour si j'ose dire
Erwan
l'un des résultats du baromètre c'est
évidemment vous avez demandé s'il y
avait toujours une voilà une opinion
majoritairement favorable ou défavorable
à la réforme ça bouge pas vraiment c'est
ça on est à 66% de de français opposés
c'est extrêmement stable dans le temps
et c'est même stable depuis ce qu'on
mesurait pendant la campagne
présidentielle lorsque le souhait de
réforme a été annoncé par Emmanuel
Macron donc ça reste profondément stable
c'est ce qui avait heurté les Français
quand on a fait quand les membres du
gouvernement ont fait de la pédagogie
les Français disent nous on a très bien
compris de quoi il s'agissait c'est
juste qu'on est opposé donc d'où la
période de la pédagogie qui a déjà mal
fonctionné et c'est vrai que les
Français restent vent debout contre
cette réforme et autres signes
intéressants même les retraités 53%
alors qu'ils étaient plutôt en dessous
la barre de 50% sont majoritairement
défavorables maintenant la réforme des
retraites également donc il y a des
Français qui sont totalement réconciliés
mais dans l'opposition à ce projet ce
qui dit de cette difficulté à s'imposer
évidemment et puis il y a aussi ce que
les Français
attendent des sénateurs sur le vote du
texte là aussi c'est intéressant
attendez-vous que les sénateurs
s'opposent à la totalité du texte oui à
37% si on rentre un peu dans le détail
vous avez posé la question avec ou sans
le
l'âge le enfin le décalage de l'âge
légal de départ qu'est-ce que ça donne
ça c'est ce que ça donne c'est que le
chiffon rouge c'est vraiment le ressort
de l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans dès lors
que ce point est enlevé les les Français
sont favorables à un vote par le Sénat
mais c'est tout l'enjeu mais en même
temps et c'est vrai c'est pour ça que le
travail parlementaire qui n'a pas été
réalisé peine peut-être à identifier des
contreparties parce que quand on parle
d'allonger la durée de cotisation les
Français sont partagés on avait des
sondages en 2013 quand il a eu la
réforme Touraine à 55 ans grosso modo
c'est cette réforme injuste socialement
qui a du mal à passer auprès des
Français parce qu'elle semble pénaliser
les femmes les ouvriers c'est ce
sentiment d'injustice finalement qui
fédère la population dans dans
l'opposition et c'est c'est tout l'enjeu
des des prochains des prochains débats
on va parler maintenant de
l'image de l'exécutif et nomment
d'Emmanuel Macron et je vous propose
d'écouter rentrer dans la République sur
ce qu'il attend du Sénat c'était samedi
lors de sa visite au salon de
l'agriculture évidemment vous parliez de
danse du ventre en tout cas la porte
elle est grande ouverte j'ai vu qu'il
voulait faire avancer les choses sur
politique familiale et les droits des
femmes et donc je pense que le
gouvernement abordera avec de
l'ouverture et de la volonté d'engagée
pour bâtir une majorité derrière ce
texte et donc je souhaite que le Sénat
puisse s'enrichir ce texte avec ce qui
lui paraît utile claire Chartier comment
vous vous analysez on commence à avoir
pas mal de recul le l'attitude ou la
stratégie je ne sais pas du président de
la République sur ce dossier il me
semble qu'il a fait deux erreurs une
première c'est de sous-estimer la
puissance du chiffre le symbole c'est à
dire que un chiffre on le sait ça marque
presque autant qu'une image dans
l'opinion publique lorsque l'opinion
publique est vraiment l'idée de ce de ce
chiffre là tabou enfin de l'âge de
report de l'âge de départ en retraite et
ton créé dans l'opinion publique après
il est très difficile de faire passer
des nuances parce qu'un chiffre c'est
toujours caricatural et donc on le voit
bien d'ailleurs ils ont lâché peu à peu
au fil des semaines des correctifs des
gens quand même fait pas mal
d'amendements à partir le premier projet
ça ne passe pas ça n'imprime pas parce
que il y a ce symbole du chiffre là
auquel il ne faut pas toucher c'est ça
l'expression que j'emploie
déterminant encore c'est à mon sens il
l'erreur tactique qui qui s'est opérée
très vite en fait si on remonte bien le
fil
le film en fait dès le début
l'opposition a été capable de d'élaborer
un contre-argumentaire tout à fait
compréhensible pour l'opinion publique
ils ont dégainé des arguments laissant
tout à fait entendre qu'il y avait
d'autres solutions financières à la
solution proposée les gens n'ont
parfaitement compris la réponse du
gouvernement ça a été de dire mais notre
réforme est juste et deuxième erreur en
fait en creusant un peu l'opposition l'a
fait c'était pas bien difficile et bien
effectivement on comprenait très vite
que au lieu de justice finalement ce qui
allaient en pâtir le plus c'était les
moins diplômés qui avaient commencé tôt
donc ces fameux français première ligne
etc donc le terme justice n'était
absolument pas adapté le gouvernement a
dû l'abandonner donc ça fait deux
cafouillages absolument magistraux et on
est en fait on retrouver dans cette
fameuse confrontation dont on sait quel
est le grand fermant de la mobilisation
sociale c'est-à-dire les élites contre
le peuple si je caricature donc on est
en plein dedans tout ça en raison d'une
succession d'erreurs à mon sens tactique
si on regarde
Erwan la popularité de l'exécutif
ça décroche quoi les deux que ce soit
Emmanuel Macron Isabelle borne souffre
dans leur dans leur chiffre de
popularité Emmanuel Macron il est stable
à un niveau bas à 36% à 36%, il retrouve
finalement son score de popularité
d'avant la crise sanitaire avant qu'ils
deviennent le président soutenu parce
que c'est un rempart face à la crise
sanitaire à la crise environnementale la
crise économique donc il redescend en
termes de popularité et si on regarde
les l'évolution de la popularité de ces
prédécesseurs on voit que François
Hollande en 2016 avec la loi travail
Nicolas Sarkozy en 2010 avec la
contestation des retraites Jacques
Chirac en 95 avec les grandes graines
ont connu leur plancher de popularité
face à des mouvements sociaux c'est tout
l'enjeu pour Emmanuel Macron parce qu'il
y a quand même un risque de
détérioration forte du lien avec les
Français dans un contexte où finalement
le macronisme originel commence un peu à
se dénaturer le macronisme de 2017 c'est
la légitimité démocratique de l'élection
pour faire des réformes avec
volontarisme quel que soit les
résistances mais aujourd'hui les
Français disent que les résistances
elles sont légitimes et ils perçoivent
le macronisme d'aujourd'hui pas du tout
comme du volontarisme dans la réforme
mais comme quelque chose d'un peu trop
autoritaire et trop vertical et si on
regarde la popularité de la première
ministre d'Elizabeth borne et si on la
compare aussi à certains de ces
prédécesseurs ça donne quoi le tableau
est assez négatif également et Isabelle
borne elle perd de points de popularité
à 29% de Français qui pensent que c'est
une bonne première ministre elle patit
plus fortement du contexte national
parce qu'elle est cantonnée sur la scène
nationale contrario d'Emmanuel Macron
30% de popularité c'est un niveau que
n'ont jamais atteint à Matignon Jean
Castex et Édouard Philippe avec ce 29%
de popularité Elizabeth borne est déjà
un niveau bas et si on regarde ses
prédécesseurs qui ont eu des codes de
popularité sous la barre des 30% on
trouve Manuel Valls 24% en pleine
contestation de la loi travail en 2016
et Dominique de Villepin en 2006
contestation du contrat 1er embauche 26
% de popularité c'est un projet qui est
même fini par être retirer donc il y a
un vrai risque politique de dénaturation
du lien entre les citoyens et le couple
exécutif Mathieu Emmanuel Macron il paye
ses erreurs tactiques telles que les a
décrites claires ils payent il y a aussi
des racines profondes j'y pensais quand
vous parliez de macronisme original
c'est quand même fait lire en nous
expliquant qu'il avait été biberonné par
Michel Rocard qui était qui incarnait ce
qu'on appelait le deuxième gauche qui
était plus sur le contrat que la loi qui
était pour le dialogue social et ça ça a
été très vite torpillé et dans son
premier quinquennat il s'est quand même
assis sur les syndicats il faut le dire
à commencer par le premier d'entre eux
le syndicat réformiste la CFDT qui passe
une nouille de liens avec Laurent Berger
il compte sidérer que les syndicats
c'était aussi des obstacles et des
résistances indus c'était d'une de rente
qui empêchait la transformation du pays
et on a eu les ordonnances sur la loi
travail au début du quinquennat il a
jamais su tisser ce lien et donc
aujourd'hui ces syndicats lui rendent un
peu la monnaie de sa pièce en lui disant
ok mais vous avez jamais voulu discuter
avec nous et là il arrive avec ses 65
ans parce que en plus c'était 65 au
départ
le fait qu'ils veulent pas dialoguer
mais enfin les syndicats sont même pas
reçus ils ont eu trois coups de fil
madame borne un dimanche de mobilisation
et depuis absolument rien donc j'ai
assez c'est c'est de la réponse du
berger à la berger ces choses d'ailleurs
est-ce qu'on va voir à l'oeuvre là
maintenant
se rééquilibrage parlementaire dont on
parle depuis le soir des élections
législatives en quelque sorte
rééquilibrage parlementaire par rapport
au Sénat
par rapport
le poids de l'exécutif et le poids le
poids du Parlement en général alors oui
non parce que c'est vrai que je rejoins
ce qui a été dit sur l'autoritarisme
c'est vrai que il y a quelque chose qui
qui passerait peu s'élever véhicule
législative de l'article 47 ans du
projet loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificatif il faut le redire
ça vous imprime une fois quand même très
spécifique ce qui fait notamment que ce
projet de loi est très court puisqu'il
faut qu'il soit ramassés
budgétaire néanmoins ici on aurait pu
s'attendre au moins à avoir un vrai
projet de loi de réforme des retraites
en tant que tel c'est-à-dire avec
également toutes les mesures
complémentaires qui ont historiquement
toujours accompagnés nos projets loi de
réformes des retraites donc ça il faut
le dire déjà on a un projet de loi de
réforme des retraites qui n'en est même
pas vraiment un dans sa forme
législative et ça c'est quand même
quelque chose d'historique ensuite sur
la question du dialogue social c'est
vrai qu'on a un Emmanuel Macron qui
prétend depuis le premier jour de la
contestation
travailler sur la légitimité élective
elle existe c'est une vérité je pense
que c'est une erreur de dire d'ailleurs
qu'on a un président mal élu ou une
assemblée mal élu voilà et c'était lu
c'est une vérité néanmoins on peut pas
opposer cette légitimité et l'active à
la légitimité populaire à partir du
moment où en fait vous êtes élu vous
êtes justement censé jouer un pas de
deux avec l'opinion et ici on voit bien
qu'il y a quelque part une démarche de
ne pas chercher à avoir ce dialogue
alors rééquilibrage au profit de
l'Assemblée ça aurait été heureux de
l'avoir dans ce moment-là mais encore
une fois en choisissant un débat
constitutionnel aussi tronqué aussi
difficile que celui de l'article 47 ans
le gouvernement était à peu près certain
de toute façon de ne pas entendre les
revendications du Parlement parce qu'on
peut se demander pourquoi ce véhicule
législatif a été choisi alors la raison
qui nous est avancée c'est l'équilibre
néanmoins on peut ajouter que de toute
façon toutes les réformes des retraites
ont été prises par des lois ordinaires
et ont donné lieu ensuite à des projets
de loi de rectification qui aurait pu se
passer tout à fait dans le consensus et
sans problème donc il y a pas vraiment
de motivation à part l'idée d'aller vite
et de pouvoir éventuellement justifier
d'un 49-3 pour engager sa responsabilité
là encore pour aller plus vite donc on a
joué la montre on a joué l'efficacité
donc non le Parlement ici ne peut
malheureusement pas prouvé que le
rééquilibrage ira en sa faveur parce que
cette assemblée chaudron est la même au
contraire démontré que parce qu'on
n'avait pas de majorité on était encore
plus fracturé dans le scénacle
parlementaire donc je crois qu'en fait
on a vraiment joué du père d'en perdre
là-dessus à charge peut-être pour le
Sénat de nous montrer qu'on peut faire
mieux
si on rentre un peu dans le détail et
Emmanuel Macron il perd des points même
chez ceux qui avaient voté pour lui au
premier tour de la de la présidentielle
alors c'est plus si c'est dans votre
baromètre dans le sondage de de d'un
autre d'un autre institution des
concurrents avec le Journal du Dimanche
en voyant votre regard je suis dit ah
c'est pas dans le haut mais du coup
effectivement le le socle de soutien à
Emmanuel Macron a tendance à s'éroder et
on a une partie aussi des sympathisants
de de renaissance qui sont opposés à la
méthode actuelle et qui n'avait pas
signé pour ce macronisme autoritaire et
vertical donc il y a quand même ce point
là aussi de la base de soutien Emmanuel
Macron parce que la réforme des
retraites n'est pas une fin il reste
quatre ans de de quinquennat et il y a
quand même beaucoup de sujets à mettre
sur la table d'ici là donc quand la
marge de soutien c'est rode dans
l'opinion ça devient de plus en plus dur
on l'a vu avec François Hollande en fin
de quinquennat c'est même de plus en
plus dur de mettre en place des réformes
alors j'ouvre maintenant un chapitre
consacré à la stratégie LR tiens une
petite question en préambule est-ce
qu'il y a des personnalités LR qui
profitent de voilà du contexte et par
exemple je pense à un Aurélien Pradier
est-ce qu'il a pu profiter alors c'est
pas très très connu par par les Français
mais est-ce qu'il a pu profiter de son
opposition à la réforme des retraites
non pas significativement c'est vrai que
l'obstruction parlementaire quelque
chose qui ne paye pas dans dans
l'opinion et on le voit parce que
finalement si on regarde les cotes
d'adhésion auprès des sympathisants LR
on est à 50% pour Éric Ciotti qui avait
déjà perdu 10 points en disant qu'il
était plutôt favorable à la réforme mais
Aurélien Pradier lui n'est qu'à 20% donc
vraiment très en retrait et la tête qui
dépasse c'est vraiment
eriki donc non on peut pas dire qu'il
est qu'il ait gagné des points dans son
opposition je pense que une volonté
consensus ou que toutes les voies
s'expriment au sein de LR mais de façon
concertée allez on va rentrer dans le
détail de cette stratégie grâce à Audrey
nous rejoindre sur ce plateau bonsoir
Audrey bienvenue avec des dissensions
qui persistent au sein des LR elle
persiste en tout cas entre Aurélien
paradis donc vous avez parlé et le reste
des LR Aurélien Pradier qui jouera
rappelle a été limogé de sa place de
vice-président exécutif du parti par
axioti la raison c'est prise de position
contre la réforme des retraites qui les
jugent injuste notamment en ce qui
concerne les carrières longues il
persiste et signe avec un nouveau tacle
contre sa famille politique et contre le
Sénat j'ai collé les deux morceaux
d'interview regardez c'est assez
virulent
je pense d'ailleurs qu'il y a un danger
à ce que notre famille politique
devienne complice conciliant du
gouvernement peu à peu j'attire
l'attention de tout le monde sur ce
petit jeu qui pourrait s'installer selon
lequel une chambre pourrait écraser
l'autre au contre le Sénat pourrait
presque se substituer à l'Assemblée
nationale je un immense respect pour les
sénateurs il ne représente pas le peuple
la représentation nationale elle est à
l'Assemblée nationale
vous le voyez c'est assez vif il
rappelle que les sénateurs ne sont pas
élus au suffrage universel direct ça
remet en cause aussi le bicamérisme
Bruno Retailleau le président DLR lui a
répondu cet après-midi à l'occasion des
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
écouté je voudrais peut-être reciter une
très belle phrase de Victor Hugo parlant
justement du bicamerisme il avait dit
Victor Hugo que la France gouvernée par
une assemblée unique ce serait l'océan
gouverné par l'ouragan vous le voyez
Thomas une citation il donne un peu
l'impression que ça lui passe au dessus
il faut dire que cette sortie médiatique
ne devrait pas avoir d'impact de gros
incidences au Sénat ou les relais
d'Aurélien Pradier sont moins nombreux
qu'à l'Assemblée le groupe LR est plutôt
homogène soudé derrière son président
Bruno Retailleau et puis il serait
difficile de se dédier de critiquer la
réforme quand ça fait quatre ans que les
LR et les centristes au Sénat vote un
amendement dans le budget de la Sécurité
sociale pour allonger justement l'âge de
départ en retraite à 64 ans l'objectif
pour les LR il n'y en a qu'un ce ne sont
pas les dissensions mais
[Musique]
paritaire elle est censée représenter un
petit peu les sensibilités de chacune
des assemblées et avec cette députée et
cette sénateur ça va très vite étant
donné que la majorité sénatoriale et
taux LR et bien évidemment les LR seront
bien représentées j'ajoute que les LR au
Sénat sont aussi la première puissance
d'opposition donc c'est assez
conflictuel aussi pour eux d'être dans
cette position aujourd'hui d'être la
majorité de projets puisque
précisément on a parlé de l'affaire
Benalla mais on pourrait citer encore
plein d'autres commissions d'enquête je
pense notamment à celle du covid qui a
été aussi pas mal où on voyait bien que
le commissure
on voit bien que le Sénat c'était
installé dans cette posture d'opposition
et encore une fois le Sénat a souvent
été dans l'opposition puisque le Sénat
est historiquement placé à droite mais
donc on peut se dire qu'en fait le Sénat
va ici se transformer en chambre d'allié
à la majorité ce qui est pas forcément
quelque chose de très facile en terme de
de posture à changer pour eux donc c'est
aussi pour ça que les sénateurs LR on le
sentiment sont des choses à jouer parce
que ils connaissent leur poids dans la
balance et parce que justement ils ont
tout intérêt à montrer que cet accord ne
va pas être facilement obtenu alors
néanmoins les questions de cohérence
aussi on l'a dit ça fait 5 ans que cet
amendement passe sur tous les PLFSS et
puis c'était dans le projet de Valérie
Pécresse donc l'austérité fait partie de
toute façon de la culture de la droite
fait partie de la culture sénatoriale
donc à partir du moment où on veut un
petit peu de cohérence il va falloir que
le Sénat aussi trouve le bon équilibre
le groupe LR il est plutôt homogène ici
au Sénat malgré tout est-ce que l'examen
de cette réforme des retraites peut être
pigeuse pour les LR révélatrices de
dissension
retraite ajouté à la nouvelle
configuration de l'Assemblée mais
vraiment en lumière finalement
la difficulté qu'à la droite est l'air
de définir ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire
d'être de droite façon LR parce que on a
on voit en fait une confrontation de
personnalité d'ego bon ça c'est c'est
assez classique à vrai mais on voit
aussi des divergences sur la stratégie à
adopter pour parce que c'est quand même
le but reconstituer remettre sur pied ce
parti et puis essayer de d'attirer un
bout un bout d'électorat et à défaut
d'avoir des personnalités comme De
Gaulle qui arrivaient à synthétiser à la
fois le conservatisme le libéralisme et
la fibre social là on se retrouve avec
des personnalités des dirigeants qui se
font traiter gauchistes enfin j’exagère
à peine pour Aurélien Pradier de l'autre
eriki qui dit moi je veux plus entendre
parler de l'aide sociale du parti et
puis un Bruno retaillod qui finalement à
la fois est très dur en affaires en
disant par exemple sur les régimes
spéciaux il faut qu'il disparaissent
d'un coup et puis à côté plus vite et
puis par ailleurs évoque la possibilité
de nos retraites anticipées pour les
gens qui se rendent la capacité et qui
est plutôt de l'ordre du registre en
tout cas
social donc allez comprendre en fait ça
tire les balles sifflent dans tous les
sens et cette droite elle tire à U et à
dire donc franchement je me demande qui
comprend quoi là-dedans
il est passionnant dans ce débat
consacré à la journée du 7 mars à one
l'estran vous avez là aussi interrogé
les Français sur leur soutien finalement
à la stratégie de l'intersyndicale ça
donne quoi 61% des Français nous disent
qu'ils soutiennent la journée de
mobilisation du 7 mars c'est un niveau
important on est juste un tout petit peu
en dessous les 65 70 % de Français qui
soutenaient les journées de contestation
précédente mais là on est quand même sur
une France à l'arrêt alors faut quand
même tempérer ce chiffre parce que ce
qu'on observait dans nos précédents
sondage c'est que autour de deux
Français sur trois uniquement où il leur
quotidien perturbé par les mouvements
récents parce qu'avec le télétravail les
choses sont différentes c'est des
manifestations sur une journée unique
donc les gens ont la possibilité de
s'organiser on n'a pas eu de grève
prolongée au-delà d'une journée mais
pour autant le soutien est très
important pourquoi parce que les gens
ont l'impression que c'est la seule
moyen le seul moyen de faire reculer
l'exécutif mais c'est intéressant parce
que donc ça c'est vous soutenez cette
journée dit oui à 61% et puis ensuite
est-ce que vous seriez favorable à des
grèves reconductibles au-delà du 7 mars
là le soutien baisse un peu il reste
important mais il baisse un peu il
baisse un peu il est de 54% plus de la
moitié des Français soutiendrait des
blocages dans la durée c'est dire la
légitimité qui accompagne cette
contestation sociale c'est un niveau
élevé en revanche c'est vrai que il y a
toujours une érosion quand le conflit
dur quand il y a des débordements dans
les cortèges qui va falloir suivre avec
attention mais en tout cas la légitimité
est vraiment du côté de la contestation
et ça se répète dans cette dans cette
configuration plus intéressant que le
contexte quand même et celui que l'on
connaît c'est-à-dire je lisais ce matin
une interview du président de Système U
et donc il parlait de la question du
pouvoir d'achat et qui disait que les
politiciens aujourd'hui
effectivement où nous en sommes et la
détresse le désarroi d'éclats des des
populations modestes ce sont ces mêmes
personnes ces mêmes gens qui vont faire
qui vont finalement passer une journée
pas payée à manifester ou à donc c'est
pas rien finalement donc ça dit beaucoup
sur l'intensité du rejet oui et il y a
un mot important que vous avez martelé
et c'est le mot légitimité c'est à dire
qu'en fait elle a basculé complètement
cette légitimité en réalité ce qui est
populaire aujourd'hui c'est d'être
hostile à cette réforme et pourtant dans
le jeu parlementaire on est en train de
se demander quels alliances vont
permettre à ce projet de passer donc on
est vraiment aujourd'hui à l'aube de
quelque chose d'assez
fracturant quand même pour notre régime
et ce qui nous est déjà arrivé par
exemple avec la crise des gilets jaunes
c'est qu'en fait l'opinion est assez
unanime est assez forte en fait du côté
de la contestation qui devient
finalement la on a le sentiment ce sont
eux qui sont devenus les représentants
puisque il y a aussi quelque chose
d'assez original par rapport à 95 c'est
que cette inter syndicale n'a pas
finalement de véritables vecteurs au
sein des assemblées on a bien vu qu'ils
étaient à l'encontre total de la
stratégie de d'obstruction de LFI mais
là on peut pas dire non plus que le
Sénat est représente réellement donc on
voit bien qu'en fait on a on a un gap
complet qui s'est créé entre
syndicale et le Parlement je suis
d'accord avec le terme fort unanime je
mettrai un bémol parce qu'il y a quand
même toujours 33% des Français qui qui
sont posés et puis surtout il y a il y a
aussi une partie des Français qui qui
vont pas aimer les images d'une d'un
pays à l'arrêt à partir du 7 mars cette
part de l'opinion elle existe elle
existe toujours oui mais on va quand
même bien en terme de popularité que il
y a pas le sinister l'hostilité initiale
qu'on aurait pu avoir avec n'importe
quel mouvement de revendication on a eu
plusieurs fois en fait on a même dit
depuis le quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
que les syndicats étaient morts en
réalité et que
tout projet de réforme sociale en
réalité passé parce que les Français
étaient résignés on a parlé de ce terme
de résignation et au finish on ne le
voit pas tellement puisque les Français
sont assez en accord avec cette idée
alors évidemment on a quand même une
France qui est fracturée puisqu'il y a
quand même une part de soutien mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est que même dans
les périodes fortes mais voilà on parle
de France à l'arrêt qu'on a des mots
très forts et bien la popularité qu'on
sait et conservée au profit de ces
syndicats donc je crois que c'est quand
même un miroir inversé de la classe
politique face à une classe politique
extrêmement divisé on a une unité
syndicale inédite depuis 12 ans face à
une une classe politique qui est propice
au débordement on a un mouvement
syndical qui fait des journées de
manifestation sans débordement sans
agressivité ce qui en plus vraiment dans
notre mémoire rétinienne est très on a
les images des gilets jaunes enfin on a
les images de la loi travail on a des
images de la loi el khomri depuis ça
fait quand même dix ans qu'on a des
contestations sociales qui sont dures
etc c'est intéressant quelle est la part
de capacité des syndicats encadrer un
mouvement et quelle est la part de
changement de stratégie de de la part de
du ministère de l'intérieur c'est il
faudrait analyser
c'est vrai mais les deux sont liés on a
quand même cette idée de d'une la force
tranquille et dans la rue je suis
d'accord et cette force tranquille oui
elle suscite plus l'adhésion de la
population parce que c'est pas le bordel
contrairement à ce que c'est de dire
jardin c'est peut-être le bordel à
l'Assemblée il accusait la francophonie
c'est pas le bordel dans la rue
en berger et donc le fait que Emmanuel
Macron l'ai attaqué sur son sens de la
responsabilité en est tombé d'autant
plus à côté parce qu'il déroule un plan
qui a été prévu et sans surprise
de l'examen de cette réforme un peu de
fatalisme c'est à dire opposition à la
réforme mais bon de toute façon elle
finira par passer est-ce que en voilà
dans la perspective de cette journée du
7 mars dans cette finalement ce soutien
assez fort affiché vous voyez en creux
se fatalisme recule et c'est à dire un
espoir chez certains Français de se dire
bah peut-être que on va réussir à faire
reculer ce gouvernement bien au
contraire on a même posé la question aux
Français il y a deux semaines et ce qui
dominait c'était la colère bien plus que
la résignation le mouvement est
galvanisé par la réussite populaire des
différentes manifestations qui a eu
parce que ça c'est quand même un point
il faut le signaler sur la mobilisation
on a plus de Français qui ont manifesté
aujourd'hui qu'en 95 à un moment où les
réseaux sociaux n'existaient pas
aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux comme
des foulards quand on veut manifester
son hostilité dans la France des réseaux
sociaux ont réussi à manifester avec
plus de gens comme 1995 c'est très
impressionnant ça c'est le le point
important est-ce qu'on observe c'est que
les Français sont en colère et sont
galvanisés par le fait que les cortèges
se déroulent dans toutes les villes avec
cortège dans les grandes villes mais
aussi dans les villes moyennes aussi
dans les petites villes donc une espèce
de voilà de d'unanimité manifestante en
tout cas de grande animaux animations
manifestants qui séduit les Français et
qui consolide le mouvement évidemment
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci aussi Mathieu
vous laissez la place puisqu'on a un
débat entre 4 scénaristes et sénatrices
qui va démarrer dans dans une minute et
donc le baromètre au doxam mascara avec
du Xena et la PQR et à lire également
chez nos confrères de la presse
quotidienne régionale ça tombe sous le
sens